[Musique]
et c'est avec vous mkel midoro bonsoir
bonsoir On commence ces informations
avec la colère des taxis après les
agriculteurs ce sont maintenant les
chauffeurs de taxis qui se mobilisent ce
matin une opération escargot a eu lieu
sur l'autoroute à 13 au départ de
mainvillier louvciienne en direction de
Paris la raison de leur colère la
nouvelle convention avec la Caisse
nationale d'assurance maladie sur le
transport sanitaire qui doit entrer en
vigueur le 1er février elle devrait
modifier les tarifications de la prise
en charge des frais de transport des
patients pour Rael actuellement un
chauffeur de taxi peut faire une remise
de 20 % du prix de la course à la
sécurité sociale or avec la nouvelle
convention les professionnels ne
connaissent pas la remise qui pourrait
s'appliquer ni les nouveaux tarifs en
vigueur on poursuit ces informations au
centre hospitalier de Versailles où des
soignants témoignent sur les conditions
de prise en charge des patients aux
urgences dans un dossier de nos
confrères du Parisien trois aides
soignantes du centre hospitalier révèle
la faillite de leurs servicees dans le
long couloir qui traverse les urgences
des brancards santasse faute de lit
parfois pendant plusieurs jours on
pouvait lire je cite des témoignage
certains restent jusqu'à 5 jours dans ce
couloir avant d'être hospitalisés où les
aides- soignantes sont souvent obligé de
les attacher ces dernières ont découvert
des patients morts tout seuls dans leur
coin des situations qui mettent donc en
danger les patients c'est en tout cas ce
que montre les résultats d'une étude
publiée en septembre est mené dans 97
services d'urgence une nuit à passer
dans un brancard augmente de 40%
le risque de mortalité des personnes
âgées face à cette situation les
syndicats tirent la sonnette d'alarme
pour le moment sans résultats le musée
de la ville de Saint-Quentin en evveline
devrait fermer ses portes pour les
rouvrir dans un autre lieu de
saint-quenttin en evveline prochainement
implanté au mumed un vaste équipement
partagé avec la médiathèque du canal le
musée de la ville devrait changer
d'adresse pour cause cet espace devrait
bientôt accueillir à l'école de
cybersécurité 2600 qui occupe
actuellement les locaux sous l'escalier
du K François truffo selon
l'agglomération de 50 ans Livine le
musée de la ville devrait déménager dans
les prochains mois à la halpano futur
quartier des savoirs de guyoncour et on
reste à Guill encour puisque la ville
organisait pour la première fois ce
weekend une gratiferia qu'est-ce que
c'est une gratiferia Michel le principe
était simple les habitants pouvaient
prendre ce dont ils avaient besoin ou
envie le tout gratuitement livre DVD
objets décoration petits objets
électriques ou électroniques joué à
vaisselle en passant par des meubles le
choix était large mais limité chaque
personne pouvait choisir entre deux ou
trois objets sur place comme l'explique
au micro de Grégory canalé François
Moron François Morton maèire de gu
encour à l'entrée on distribue quatre
jetons trois jetons d'une couleur et un
jeton rouge le jeton rouge permettant
d'avoir accès à une table qui est celle
des objets avec un peu plus de valeur et
donc les personnes peuvent échanger
leurs jetons contre un objet de leur
choix des objets qui ont été déposés par
des habitants tout au long de la la
semaine dernière parmi les donateurs il
y a marieclaude on l'écoute j'ai déposé
un
halogène des petites choses de couture
des rest que j'avais voilà un coussin
aussi pour poser l'ordinateur enfin
voilà des choses dont on avait plus
l'utilité et habituellement on va on va
faire la Ressourcerie mais là c'est
quelque chose je connaissais déjà les
gratiferia et je trouve ça vraiment
formidable que ça ça va se développer
peut-être sur encs cette initiative est
issue du centre social et de la
responsable du service transition
écologique de la mairie accompagné par
ressourcez-vous gestionnaire de la
Ressourcerie de guancour ainsi que par
le Conseil citoyen de quartier au total
une dizaine de bénévoles ont permis
l'organisation de cette première édition
pour trier et organiser les objets et
comme chaque année samedi la ville de
Rambouillet Élisée sa nouvelle
ambassadrice de la jeunesse rambolitaine
c'était samedi soir et la reine du
muguet 2024 et Adria Nina Andria Mino
Harin nozi candidate numéro 2 elle
représentait l'association des des
commerçants de Rambouillet on écoute sa
réaction au micro de Grégory canali je
suis vraiment très surprise ça me fait
vraiment très plaisir et c'est surtout
de la joie je suis vraiment très
heureuse pour maîre reen du muguet c'est
représenter l'association des
commerçants dans les valeurs de du
partage et de
l'unité à ses côtés deux autres
candidates ont été élu Mélina zaïz
Garmin première dauphine candidate de
rambouiller sport Basket et Emma Guiry
2e dauphine représentant à l'association
une rose un espoir qui lutte contre le
cancer du sein au total SEP candidates
étaient en LCE on le rappelle chaque
année depuis 1911 rbouillé Ellie une
reine du muguet lors de la nuit du
muguet pendant un an la reine et ses
dauphines deviennent les ambassadrices
de la jeunesse de la ville et tout au
long de leur couronnement elles seront
conviées aux différentes manifestations
organisées par la ville de Rambouillet
bien merci beaucoup Michel midoro pour
toutes ces informations comme d'habitude
si vous aussi vous voyez une image ou
une actualité qui vous fait agir
n'hésitez pas à nous la partager sur les
réseaux sociaux en utilisant le hashtag
78 news